hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's was
schnelles bis haben nämlich meine
schwester und ich als kinder immer
gemacht deshalb ist es auch wirklich
kinderleicht und ihr braucht nicht viele
zutaten und er offen bleibt sowieso aus
wir machen nämlich eine waffel dessert
mit creme und kirsch plätze und hier
vorne zeige ich euch jetzt mal die
zutaten
wir benötigen muss selbst gekaufte
frische waffeln außerdem tier spritze
die könnt ihr selber machen oder kaufen
hier habe ich schlag sahne magerquark
außerdem schmand oder ihr könnt auch
creme fraiche nehmen etwas vanille
extrakt puderzucker und sahne fest wir
bereiten jetzt zuallererst die creme vor
da habe ich mir eine große schüssel
genommen ein handrührgerät und jetzt
gebe ich dazu allerersten max sack und
schmand rein wie gesagt ihr könnt ihr
schwant auch durch creme fraiche
ersetzen schmeckt auch sehr lecker und
wichtig ist auch dass alle zutaten schön
kalt aus dem kühlschrank kommen
so in die schüssel habe ich jetzt
außerdem noch puderzucker für die süße
gegeben und für den geschmack noch etwas
vanille extra aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch gerne vanillezucker nimmt was auch
sehr gut schmeckt ist der abrieb einer
bio zitrone das mache ich auch sehr
gerne und jetzt gebe ich hier die kalte
schlagsahne rein
das mache ich mal gerne am schluss damit
sie nicht so spritzt und nichts dreckig
wird
und jetzt machen wir den mitschülern und
nixon das ganze erstmal schön auf
niedriger stufe und gehen dann immer
höher und die masse ist schon richtig
schön dick geworden aber noch nicht
steigt in die saane darin ich muss ja
steif geschlagen werden und zur hilfe
nehmen und jetzt unser seine fest das
weiß ich jetzt noch ein riesen und dass
es dann nochmal auf höchster stufe
richtig schön fest aufschlagen
[Musik]
so im leben hier steht alles bereit
unsere leckere creme außerdem hier
spritze und unsere waffen und ich habe
jetzt hier eine auflaufform genommen und
ich werde euch auf jeden fall die maße
in die infobox schreiben aber ihr müsst
euch nicht an diesem maße halten ihr
könnt auch ein bisschen abweichen das
ist kein problem denn jetzt nehme ich
mir die waffen geschichte wie sie jetzt
zuallererst auf den boden so der boden
steht jetzt gebe ich die hälfte der
creme drauf übrigens haben soll wird das
dein geburtstags küchlein darf man sagen
bisher
morgens haben das geburtstag und sorry
keine zeit mehr
ja das ist aber auch wirklich lecker
designs verstreiche ich das erste stück
so jetzt kommt die kür spritze zum einen
natürlich kann man hier auch selber
machen das doch ganz einfach das zeige
ich euch auch bei nächster gelegenheit
die hin ist jetzt selbst gekauft und ich
brauche auch nicht so viel ich nehme
immer so ein bisschen mehr für die deko
für die fotos ihr braucht auf jeden fall
nicht so viel wie ich hier habe und
jetzt verteilen mir die auf der sahne
creme zu niveaulos richtig was ist genau
das ist der plan
[Musik]
so und als nächstes nehmen wir uns
wieder eine schicht der waffe und
drücken das ein bisschen an so beim eine
auflaufform jetzt oben ein bisschen
breiter ist kann man sich die waffen
auch zurechtschneiden auf die waffe
hingeben wehrt die zweite hälfte unserer
creme und dann machen wir uns gleich mit
unserer kirche sein schönes muster also
seid dann gleich etwas sparsamer so
jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu unserem
schönen muster ich gebe jetzt nur etwas
von der kirche da oben drauf und zwar
auch nicht so viel von den früchten
sondern mehr von der flüssigkeit
verteile das hier immerhin so strengen
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehmen uns eine gabe und
machen dieses words rhein zeigt euch das
mal kein sitz richtig schick aus
so das gestell ist fertig ich lieber
jetzt für den kontrast noch gerne
minzblätter lege ich dann einfach
unregelmäßig da drauf und es schmeckt am
besten wenn ihr das jetzt noch zwei
stunden in den kühlschrank gibt denn ihr
müsst euch vorstellen
die creme wird richtig schön fest und
die waffeln werden schön weich also ihr
könnt die richtige mit der gabel
durchschneiden und das ganze genießen
wichtig ist nur nach dem deckel drauf
und dann genießt das mit euren liebsten
ich mache jetzt hier noch die deko dann
sehen wir uns im auto wieder
[Musik]
wo ich hoffe jetzt natürlich dass euch
diese schnitte zur abwechslung und auch
gefallen hat es muss ja nicht immer was
aufwendiges sein und wenn ihr mal keine
zeit hat dann kommt ihr eben nicht mit
leeren händen wenn nächstes jahr hier
das ist mein beweisvideo nächstes jahr
gibt es eine fette torte für hansa zum
geburtstag
ihr seid meine zeuge erinnert mich
freuen wenn ich das vergessen sollte
schön also wenn man jetzt solche zum
besuch geht und keine zeit hat dann geht
man nicht mit leeren händen oder wenn
sich besuch ankündigt ich finds auch
übrigens super erfrischende schmeckt
total erfrischend sehr sehr lecker
profis unbedingt mal aus die genauen
mengenangaben findet die hohen zielen
der infobox und dann freue ich mich
natürlich wenn ihr meinen kann kostenlos
abonniert mehr eindeutig nach oben da
lassen wir bewegen uns auch beim
nächsten mal auf die skatingski